my house had a wife and three beautiful
daughters this trip because it's the one
time of year I get to pee standing up
somebody shot me in the head hey Leslie
what are you doing here why are you
sleeping I just I thought maybe you'd
want to talk more about all the crazy
stuff going on I do I really do with
thanks yeah I just go tell you I'm a
little tired okay so I may have parked
on your front lawn oh you did I did yeah
Leslie and I had an amazing talk it was
so great of her to come over here even
though she was exhausted beyond belief
anyway after we talked she fell asleep
on my couch and she's been asleep for 22
hours
it's amazing what she slept through okay
at one point I thought she was up : hi
Hey but then she went right back to
sleep I've been monitoring her vital
signs she's totally fine I love her so
much but I think I'm gonna draw a
mustache on her face
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's enough you almost had me again
but seeing you pick on this pathetic
defenseless little man
Hey he reminded me what kind of a
monster you are you're a joke you're not
even a man anymore oh and by the way
last night I faked four out of the seven
so did I let's go son
[Music]
kunshi well
when streams are ripe and swelled with
rain
ladies and gentlemen we are gathered
here today to marry Andrew Maxwell Dwyer
and April Roberta legend I guess I kind
of hate most things but I never really
seemed to hate you so I want to spend
the rest of my life with you is that
cool yes is it my turn
April you are the most awesome person I
have ever known in my entire life I vow
to protect you from danger I don't care
if I have to fight an ultimate fighter
or a bear or him your mom I would take
him down I'm getting mad right now even
thinking about it I'm telling you okay
this snake juice is basically a rat
poison everybody's Wiseman you don't
even know what think I didn't even say
what they get it she asked me the whole
thing and I didn't do it what I'm like
an elephant okay if I walk into a room
it's like okay he's in there Baba Booey
turns music down [ __ ] I feel phenomenal
yeah you come into me Kenneth and I
pretend that I did then we got another
role playing in the only trophy she read
to me
what's 5,000 times better than a candle
in the wind this song is called 5,000
candles in the wind
up in horsey heaven here's a thing you
trade your legs for angel's wings and
once we've all said it bad you take a
running
Mannie learned of line
[Music]
bastard
[Music]
you
in
I'm very angry I'm angry that Bobby
Newport would hold this town hostage and
threaten to leave if you don't give him
what he wants it's despicable
corporations are not allowed to dictate
what a city needs that power belongs to
the people
Bobby Newport and his daddy would like
you to think it belongs to them I love
this town and when you love something
you don't threaten it you don't punish
it you fight for it you take care of it
you put it first as your city councilor
I will make sure that no one takes
advantage of Pawnee if I seem too
passionate it's because I care if I come
on strong it's because I feel strongly
and if I push too hard it's because
things aren't moving fast enough this is
my home you are my family and I promise
you I'm not going anywhere
holy bless he that was awesome
[Applause]
yeah my my name just came out of your
mouth well yeah it did well this isn't
happening
this isn't real no it's it's happening
and I'm delighted to have you here on
behalf of the president myself I owe mr.
vice president I am deeply flattered but
there's no way that I could take over
madam secretary Clinton's position
bringing I'm confident you could do that
job or any other but well the reason
you're here is I'm told you've done such
a great job in your town and the state
of Indiana and I just want to say
congratulations for your public service
I just wanna say thank you
well you're very welcome you're very
welcome
[Music]
laughs with me but he just with me buddy
don't let her get the best of me but
don't ever let me start feeling lonely
[Music]
if I ever needed you buddy
you know now I really do but don't ever
let me start feeling lonely well this is
different from what I expected to find
good morning Leslie what did you do the
day office Ron you're wearing my yoga
clothes are gonna stretch out the
elastic I'm sorry are you leaving I
thought we had a meeting no we do it's
just I think it's a little chilly in
here
are you okay your eyes are glassy oh my
god oh my she she's sick are you sick no
yeah she's sick that's why I'm wearing
this and misting myself with hand
sanitizer I am not sick I just have
allergies okay
I took a claritin and I threw that up so
I took another one I threw that up and
then I took a third and it stayed down
I'm getting better all right you're
burning up you're burning up what I have
to get out of here
I have 2.8 percent body fat my body's
like a microchip a grain of sand could
destroy it my body's a microchip Leslie
go home no I can't
I can't go home has to get ready for the
Chamber of Secrets if this meeting does
not go perfectly then the harvest
festival is gonna be over before it
began I cannot go home okay then who is
your doctor Ann's my doctor and she's
the most beautiful nurse in the world
come on no it's really hot okay well
that's your fever let's say I typed your
symptoms into the thing up here and it
says you could have network connectivity
problems
you